[Musique]
bonjour Laurent Legendre directeur
régional et Airbus développement
bonjour je suis gaudine Soler je suis la
fondatrice de rakorak une startup social
qui développe une solution industrielle
de recyclage des plastiques orphelins
pour fabriquer des matériaux qui
viennent remplacer le bois dans beaucoup
d'applications
[Musique]
avec rectorygues pour abuser
développement est un partenariat de
territorial on travaille de deux façons
différentes l'une avec Airbus pour la
collecte des masques du site d'Élancourt
qui a été une opération pilote pour
prouver la faisabilité de se recyclage
dans le process rectorak comme un déchet
non recyclable qu'on peut intégrer dans
notre recette matériaux une grosse
avancée technologique personne ne le
faisait avant c'est la première fois que
ça se fait en France à ma connaissance
et ça nous a paru très intéressant
d'autant plus intéressant on a pu en
faire la promotion pendant le covid et
qu'on a permis de trouver une solution
pour recycler les masques d'Airbus qui
n'étaient pas recyclables et l'autre
c'est une collaboration avec Airbus
développement au travers d'un prêt
participatif Airbus développement a
souhaité nous encourager dans la
création d'emploi la plus locale
possible autour de son implantation dans
les Yvelines j'ai vu autre chose j'ai vu
aussi un projet industriel sur le
territoire qui va générer des emplois et
qui est en train de faire sa première
implantation industrielle qui est en
train de prendre ses locaux industriels
et il y aura aussi à mon avis des
partenariats parce que avec ces
matériaux là on peut faire aussi du
mobilier urbain
[Musique]
nous a proposé de réaliser des devis
pour différents types d'aménagements des
produits concrets sur mesure pour les
besoins d'Airbus ou des produits plus
standards qui existent déjà dans notre
catalogue le guéridon sur lequel je
m'appuie est un guérison dans lequel il
y a 10 % de masques recyclés et c'est un
guéridon qui frappe probablement
partie du mobilier du site aujourd'hui
on a standardisé le mange debout que
vous voyez ici des bancs des tables
basses et des tabourets on est en train
de créer des bac à plantes on est en
train de créer également des panneaux de
séparation c'est un véritable véritable
pièce utilisable et probablement avec un
prix commercial attractif puisque le
matériau de base ne vaut rien
[Musique]